[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to Episode Number
160 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm
here with my colleague,
Gabi Ferrara.
Hello, Gabi.
How are you doing today?
GABI FERRARA: Hello, Mark.
I'm good.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
Thank you so much for
joining me on the podcast.
It's very exciting to
be working with you.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, first time.
So let's see how that goes.
MARK MANDEL: I think
it's going to go great.
Before we get into
the podcast, do you
want to tell people a
little bit about yourself,
just so they get to know you?
GABI FERRARA: So I'm
[INAUDIBLE] here.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google Cloud for storage
and databases, mostly
focusing on Cloud SQL, which
it is [INAUDIBLE]
MySQL and PostgreSQL.
And sometimes, I do other
stuff, like make Memorystore,
or getting it in the
middle of stuff that's none
of my business, like Knative.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Yeah, speaking of
Knative, that is
what we we're going to
be talking about today.
So we're going to be
talking with Ville and Mark,
talking about Knative, and all
the things you can do about it.
And then after that, we're
going to have our usual question
of the week, where I'm going to
ask Gabi a question about Cloud
SQL, and how long it
takes to detect an outage
and trigger high
availability failover.
Are you ready?
GABI FERRARA: OK.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
We always do our cool
things of the week.
Gabi, do you want to go first
with one of your cool things
of the week.
GABI FERRARA: So we are
opening a new renewable energy
plant in Asia right now.
We only had before in
Americas and Europe.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
GABI FERRARA: So
Google announced
that they're doing a new
renewable energy plant in Asia.
And that's cool
because before we only
had in America and Europe.
So that's going to be a 10
megawatt plants of solar array,
and I don't know how
much that powers.
But I think it powers a lot
of stuff on data centers.
MARK MANDEL: I think it's a lot.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And we'll have a
link to some details
of that in a blog post in
the show notes as well.
I'm really excited,
because we're getting
Go-ing with Cloud Functions.
[OOHING]
That's a terrible pun as well.
But Go 1.1 is now a
supported language
on Cloud Functions, which
makes me really happy,
because I write really
terrible JavaScript,
and I'm trying to
write Cloud Functions,
and it's always a mess.
Now I can write it in
a language that I'm
am much more familiar with.
So if you want to
play with that,
that is available now in
beta, which is awesome.
So you can write HTTP
functions with Go,
you can run it against events.
So if you're a Go
lover like I am,
you can take advantage
of that right now.
GABI FERRARA: Another cool
thing of the week, it's
the Google Game
of the Year, which
used a Cloud text-to-speech
API in App Engine,
and they talk about how they
were able to save costs,
not having to hire a new
actor every time they needed
to add new stuff on
their game, and also
being scalable with App Engine.
So give it a shot at
that blog post there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You can actually go straight
to the link and bring it up.
It's actually a really cute
game that you can play.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I really like it.
It's fun.
GABI FERRARA: Finally, we also
have a new blog post series
by fellow developer relations
person, Megan O'Keefe,
who is a developer programs
engineer, talking about Istio.
So it's a series of articles
talking about Istio and how
it plugs into a
variety of things,
actually, that I really like.
So it's a basic discussion about
sort of having service mesh,
and where that's applicable.
But then also going
into where that's
been integrated into things
like Knative, talking about
multicluster Istio,
all that kind of stuff.
So I'm going to have a link
to the first one that's
in the show notes.
But keep an eye out for
follow-up articles after that.
Awesome.
Well, Gabi, why don't we
go chat with our guests
and learn all about Knative?
GABI FERRARA: OK.
Let's go.
MARK MANDEL: So big thanks
to Mark Chmarny and Ville
Aikas for joining us today
to talk about Knative.
Thanks so much for joining us.
How are you doing today, Ville?
VILLE AIKAS: I'm doing great.
Thanks for having us.
I'm really excited to
talk about Knative.
So thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And how are you doing, Mark?
MARK CHMARNY: Doing good.
Excited as well with Ville
and talking about Knative.
Thank you for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Awesome.
So before we get
stuck into Knative,
do you want to tell us a
little about who you are
and what you do?
Ville, why don't you go first?
VILLE AIKAS: I'm one of
the founders of the Knative
project.
That's something that
I've been working on
for the last year and
a half almost now.
Prior to that, I'd
been working on
several open-source projects,
Helm, Kubernetes service
catalog, and so forth.
And before that,
worked on Kubernetes
before it got open sourced.
And then, a stint in
Google Cloud Storage.
So all cloud, all the time.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Mark, you want to fill up?
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
I'm a Technical Program Manager
for Serverless at Google.
Recently, however,
I've been much more
closer to a developer
advocate type of role, working
on a Knative
open-source project,
as well as the GKE item,
which is based on a Knative.
That kind of
transition of the role
really came from the early days,
where we were super scrappy.
We had a small team on
Knative, and everybody
did two or three jobs.
But as the team grows and
we're bringing new people on,
I'm much more focused on Knative
ecosystem, driving community
awareness, partners,
contributors,
speaking engagements,
blogs, demos, and so forth.
So I'm excited to
work more and more
with the outside
contributors to Knative.
GABI FERRARA: OK.
Thank you, Mark.
We're happy to have you
here to talk about Knative.
And I would be really happy to
learn a bit more about Knative
today, because my knowledge
is a bit thin on this subject.
I just know a bit of
Kubernetes, and I'm really
excited to see what you have to
show us about the subject here.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Why don't you give us sort
of a high-level overview
of like, what's the problem
that Knative is trying to solve?
VILLE AIKAS: Sure.
So one of the things that
we did with the Kubernetes
was we really--
this is my words.
I think we gave the cloud
and the developers assembly
language for the cloud.
So you want to go
and get stuff up
and running in the cloud,
the instruction set,
if you will, and
provided Kubernetes.
And Kubernetes is great.
Problem is that
there's a lot of pieces
that we had to go ahead
and understand in order
to effectively use it.
And for the most part, the
developers don't really
need to know all
those things, ideally,
but they are exposed
to it in order for them
to actually get
things up and running.
So as we looked
around for a while,
we realized that there is
a need for a higher level
abstraction at
Kubernetes level that
would allow us to go ahead and
meet the developers' need much
more closely.
And that's sort of
where the Knative comes.
So if you think about the
Kubernetes and even Istio
as well as kind of
the assembly language,
Knative is bringing you
something like the [? Lipsy ?]
or standard [? lip. ?]
That's how I think about it.
So there's a lot of
the problems that
are being solved all over
the place, especially
in the serverless
space, and we kind of
wanted to bring all of our
friends and all the knowledge
and solve those
problems in one place,
and then go ahead
and focus on building
super awesome developer
experiences on top of that.
MARK CHMARNY: If I could just
maybe add something to this,
I think there should
be no surprise
to the regular audience
of this podcast
that Google, they're big
on Kubernetes and Istio.
MARK MANDEL: Little bit.
MARK CHMARNY: If we kind
of look a little higher
up the stack where the
developers of applications
on Kubernetes actually are,
I think, to some degree,
they just want to write code.
They don't want to deal
with building Docker images,
uploading them to registry,
deploying different services,
exposing them to the
internet, and all
the other mechanical
things that are related
to deploying an application.
So at the end of the
day, really Knative
solves for the experience of
the developer on Kubernetes
that would not require them
to know every single aspect
of what Kubernetes is.
And the analogy that Ville uses
around the low-level kernel,
it's spot on.
It's kind of something
that we're hoping nobody
ever has to think
about when they
are developing applications
on Knative, what's underneath.
GABI FERRARA: I have a question.
So you say that you
don't want developers
to be worrying about every
aspect of Kubernetes, of how
to create a load
balancer, for instance.
Knative would solve
that problem for you?
Like, they are load balancer
[INAUDIBLE] to expose the load
balancing--
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: --on Kubernetes.
And my question I ask,
because a lot of the problems
that people have,
it's because we
need to create a Docker image,
so you have a YAML file there,
then you have YAML
file for Kubernetes.
And does Knative
solve that problem,
to have to deal with
different configuration files
to do just one deployment?
MARK CHMARNY: That's
an excellent question.
I'm sure Ville can
speak to that too,
being closer to
the technical side.
But on the developer
side, I think the things
that you will see that directly
speak to that kind of friction
that you just described is being
able to skip the entire Docker
image as a requirement
for somebody who
wants to use Knative.
So we have use cases
[? where ?] address directly
deploying from a source
code, and Knative still
builds the Docker image
for you behind the scene,
but you, as a developer,
don't have to worry about it.
Furthermore, just like
you have pointed out,
once you deploy that
thing, usually people
are excited because the Hello
World application comes up.
But if you're looking at kind
of day two or day five problems
where the application
is now successful,
and dealing with some of
the autoscaling problems
that developers normally
have to deal with,
this is another area where
Knative really helps you,
because you don't have
to think about it.
It's based on autoscaling.
And when you're
audience goes away,
so does the resources
that are required to run
your application in Knative.
GABI FERRARA: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Now this
sounds really cool.
So just to take a step back
a little bit in some ways.
Like, we said sort of like,
we're deploying things.
We're deploying applications.
Like, what does
that mean to you?
Am I like, deploying
Redis with this?
Or what kind of
things am I deploying?
VILLE AIKAS: That's
a great question.
Yeah.
So typically, the first target
market really for Knative
is what is typically
the serverless, a.k.a.
Stateless services.
It is things like functions.
You want to make sure that
you have a very similar user
experience for both of
the developer experience,
for both of these, whether it's
an application, or a function,
so you don't have to go and
have that mental shift, which
is, oh, I'm doing
function-y stuff,
or I'm doing
application-y stuff,
when typically the lifecycle
and the development processes
and practices are
very, very similar.
You have some code that I
would like you to run for me,
and don't screw it up, please.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Are there particular
languages that
are supported in
Knative now, or can I
bring my own stack if I want?
VILLE AIKAS: Bring
your own stack.
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
That's the beauty of Knative.
The word that we keep
using to describe that
is this idiomatic experience.
If you were developing
applications in Node, Java,
Python, C#, you bring that
same exact experience,
and you don't change your day to
day operations to kind of adapt
to Knative.
You follow the
same procedures you
would develop your
application somewhere else.
There is no extra
attributes you have to put
on top of your functions.
There is no extra configuration
inside of your code
that you have to do in order
to make it work for Knative.
Knative is kind of
built on the assumption
that there is a serverless
container that we will run,
and we also hope you would
build in that container.
To a large degree, Knative is
polyglot from that standpoint.
Anything that can
be containerized
can be run on Knative,
as long as it's,
right now, HTTP application.
VILLE AIKAS: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So I can write functions in,
like, Haskell or something.
[LAUGHTER]
VILLE AIKAS: If that's
what you like, yes.
GABI FERRARA: Even PHP?
VILLE AIKAS: Even PHP.
GABI FERRARA: I know not
a lot of people like it,
but like, even PHP?
MARK CHMARNY: Yes.
Yes.
GABI FERRARA: I like it.
MARK CHMARNY: Even PHP.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So if I want to build like,
a little Knative application,
what does that
experience look like?
How does the tooling work?
What does that flow look like?
MARK CHMARNY: Knative kind of
has two different entry points,
so to speak.
For people kind of familiar
already with Kubernetes itself,
and they've been kind of used
to interacting with kubectl,
the command line for,
the CLI, for Kubernetes,
you can just follow the
exact same methodology.
You build your application,
you build your container,
and you deploy it, except
that when it lands,
it kind of lands as
a Knative service
that inherits a lot of the
properties of the platform I
just explained, which is
like autoscaling and being
able to be configured
dynamically, and so forth.
Your routes management.
If, however, you're coming
to Knative as a developer who
has not worked on top
of Kubernetes before,
there's a growing number
of tools in the community
to kind of enable you to
deal directly with the code,
and not have to build
images yourself.
So the use case of
a source to a URL
is one that we
often point to where
you develop the application,
for example, in Go.
And using the build pipelines
that are developed inside
of Knative, you can
actually execute a pipeline
which will build that
code from your repository,
private or public, on Git
or GitHub, inside that code
and build that image
for you and deploy it.
So all of that is happening on
the cluster, which gives you
a lot of benefits around
kind of obfuscating data,
or using the resources only
during the build phase,
and then being able to use
them to host your application
after the fact.
MARK MANDEL: Is
there tooling as well
for, like, local
development, or do I
have to push everything
up to the cloud
every time I'm working?
MARK CHMARNY: We do have
some initial implementation
of Knative on top of Minikube.
Obviously, some of
the requirements
that come with
Istio and Kubernetes
are a little more
resource hungry.
But we have people who have
successfully done that,
so you could actually imagine
running the entire stack
on your local laptop.
Yes.
VILLE AIKAS: But in most
cases, you don't even
need the entire stack,
because you can [INAUDIBLE]
or just stay in
local web server,
or run only unit
tests and integration
tests and everything else,
and then the kinds of things
that you might not
care about when
you do a local development,
like, well, does
its scale to zero, does
it go away, it's like,
no, no, no, it does.
Don't worry about it.
Just push it in the cloud,
and we'll handle that for you.
So that's kind of the
operational aspect
that we hide for you that you
typically don't necessarily
have to worry about when
you're doing local development.
But as Mark pointed
out, yeah, you
can do that with the
Minikube or anything else.
MARK CHMARNY: And GCP provides
developers with a free tier,
and I think with
our latest release,
we actually have a
model in which you could
use the free tier to run small
instance, single node instance,
of Knative on GKE.
GABI FERRARA: We list
on our Knative website
four features in
the [INAUDIBLE],,
mainly serving build events
and serverless [INAUDIBLE] GKE.
I have a question
regarding about events.
We say here that it would
be a universal subscription,
delivery and
management of events,
would be that similar
to a Pub/Sub service,
or it's a different
kind of event?
What do you mean
by events in here?
VILLE AIKAS: That's
a great question.
So eventing typically lends
itself very well to Knative
execution environment, because
it's serverless, right?
So if no events are
happening, aka, a tree
falls in the forest,
nobody hears about it.
Right?
But the eventing is a
piece that says, look,
we want to have
[? the very ?] principle
to understand the events.
So in a Pub/Sub event,
for example, happens,
or somebody publishes
an event into a Pub/Sub,
you want to say, please
execute this function for me.
And yes, we support that.
That was the direct
answer to your question.
But in addition to it,
it might be something
that somebody pushed
some code to GitHub,
or somebody uploaded an image
to Google Cloud Storage, or S3,
or whatever else, where
there's an action,
some other system
happened, and you
want to decouple
those in such a way
that you don't have to
understand, how did it happen?
You just say, you know what?
When something happens over
there, let me know about it.
So the eventing, you can
go ahead and describe
what these events look like.
And then you can go and
describe strategies, a.k.a.,
what should happen
when that event fires.
So if you want to
do something simple,
like thumbnailing, which is
a pretty classic example,
you would say, OK, when somebody
uploads an image into a Cloud
Storage bucket, please
go ahead and run
this little piece of code.
So that's what the eventing
concerns itself with.
GABI FERRARA: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And does that mean as well that
you can extend that eventing
mechanism?
So if you want to
have your own custom
events for, I don't
know, random things that
happen inside maybe your
application or something,
could you respond to those?
VILLE AIKAS: Yeah, absolutely.
That's one of the things
that makes me super excited,
is the fact that I do think
that this model of computing
is going to be made so
much more approachable
to different people, if you have
a very rich eventing ecosystem.
So the more events you
have, the more desire there
is to go and process
those, and so forth.
So being able to go ahead
and create new event sources
is something that we have
been thinking about very hard,
and making sure that
that is very, very easy,
and it behaves and looks
the same everywhere.
So I personally would like
to go ahead and make sure
that you, as a
developer, again, don't
have to worry about reading
a whole bunch of instructions
and clicking and dragging and
copying and pasting for to say,
hey, just give me those events.
'Cause that's what I care
about as a developer,
not about how does it happen.
I say, give me some events.
GABI FERRARA: So you
don't need to have
a [INAUDIBLE] running
inside Knative
to be able to get my events.
I can use Knative itself to
manage those events for me?
VILLE AIKAS: Yes.
MARK CHMARNY: One
of the nice things
that I like to talk about
eventing that often registers
with the community, or the
developers outside, who often
don't deal with Knative
on a daily basis,
is the decoupling
of the event source
from the actual
processing of events.
So when you are
writing something
that's supposed to act when
it's triggered by event,
you really don't
have any awareness
or any code in your
little processor
that is aware of that, which
means that you can bind
that processor and processing
function to a number
of different events, as long as
that message type is defined.
And this is where
Knative also is
pretty innovative with regards
to adopting CloudEvents, which
is kind of a common
way of defining events
across the internet,
which is strongly typing
the different properties
that each event will have,
while allowing for extensions
of the different data
components that come with that.
So Knative supports
CloudEvents 0.2
right now, which is the
current version of CloudEvents.
VILLE AIKAS: Yep.
MARK CHMARNY: And this is where
the industry is collaborating
and making sure that
we are able to talk
to each other as the
number of different sources
increases over time.
MARK MANDEL: Is that, like,
an open standard or something?
MARK CHMARNY: Yes.
It is actually a CNCF,
I believe, project.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I
didn't know about that.
All right.
So from the other side,
and you touched on it
a little bit earlier--
so as a developer, I'm
like, this sounds awesome.
I love it.
But how do I install this?
How do I run this?
Like, what does the operator
experience kind of look
like here?
MARK CHMARNY: Because this
is an open-source project,
you actually can take the
installation guides that
are already published in a
repository and deploy Knative
to any Kubernetes-certified
instance of a service.
So, obviously, GCP has a great
Kubernetes service called GKE.
But other cloud service
providers also have that.
You can also install to your
own Kubernetes on-premise.
So the decision would
be basically based
on the fact of two factors.
One is the locality, as in, do
you need to have applications
somewhere close, located
to your data source that's
not available somewhere
else, or something like that,
or to the operational model?
If you are already managing
your own Kubernetes cluster,
installing Knative
on top of that
would be potentially a nominal
set of scripts that you
install, and be done with that.
However a growing
number of companies
are actually not interested in
operating their own Kubernetes
cluster.
They like the
common API, and they
like that kind of certification
across different cloud service
providers, but being able
to deploy those applications
on top of that service,
and not be locked
into a particular provider.
So Knative in that case
works very well with GKE.
At Next last year-- so it's
been probably seven months--
we've launched GKE
add-on that, by including
one additional flag or
one checkbox during the UI
provisioning, you can bring
the entire Knative stack that's
been validated to work for
that particular version of GKE.
So out of the box, you're
getting the full, Knative stack
that's already
configured for you,
and you're ready to develop your
first application as soon as
that stack is available.
GKE currently takes
about, what, three minutes
to provide the entire stack.
So you have a pretty quick
provisioning capability
for yourself.
GABI FERRARA: Back tracking
a bit on the example
that Mark gave, oh, that means
I can run Redis on Knative,
and Ville said, no, it's more
stateless applications, right?
So what kind of
application or code
should I not be running
inside of Knative?
I'm a big advocate for
not running databases
inside Kubernetes,
because working
in stateful applications
is complicated.
So is that true
also for Knative?
VILLE AIKAS: So let me
make sure I understand.
So you're saying that stateful
applications shouldn't
be running on Knative?
GABI FERRARA: I'm asking that.
VILLE AIKAS: Yeah,
so typically not,
because one of the
things that we want to do
is provide the pay
as you go model,
so that resources
are not being used.
Typically, most
stateful applications
require you to have something
up and running all the time.
However, because Knative is
built on top of Kubernetes,
one of the things
that you can do
is that you can run all these
things alongside your Knative,
and you just reach out to
the Kubernetes directly.
So I know while you might
not be a fan of running
stateful applications
even on Kubernetes,
you do have that
option, because there
is a lot of great abstractions
in the Kubernetes [INAUDIBLE],,
you know, like
standardizing disks
and everything else like that.
GABI FERRARA: Yes.
VILLE AIKAS: So with
things like that,
you can go ahead and get
the best of both worlds,
if you will.
It's the developers
that really want
to focus on the stateless
applications and functions.
They can go ahead and
run in the same cluster.
They just have a
different API that
is a higher level that targets
only the things that they
should really have
to worry about.
GABI FERRARA: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And that
actually probably
segues nicely into what I'm
thinking about, which is,
so if I'm running the
managed version of Knative,
do I still have access
to a Kubernetes API?
Like, the Kubernetes cluster
that it's working on?
Or is that completely hidden
from me at that point in time?
MARK CHMARNY: It is
still available to you.
When you check that extra
box or include, then,
one extra flag during
the gcloud command
to provision the cluster,
you're really not
losing any of that
Kubernetes capability.
You're adding one extra
item on top of that.
So you still have
that Kubernetes API
if you wanted to.
You can interact
directly with Knative
for the applications that
don't require the entire stack.
But we're trying to not
hide any of the capabilities
that Kubernetes has because,
obviously, it's popular,
and it's really being adapted
by a lot of different companies.
So there's no point
of doing this.
But in the same time,
for the developers who
don't need to know the
entire scope of the schema
for a particular deployment
or service, kind of creating
a very well-defined
principle objects
that are easy to understand for
a developer, service, route,
a configuration.
It's something that,
just by understanding
the meaning of the
word, you kind of
know what it's supposed to do.
Great credit goes to the
initial thought leaders on this,
like Ville and
others, who kind of
thought about, what
would I call that?
What would I need to do
if I was a web developer
and wanted to create
something there?
So I think that has proven
to be a very elegant way
of addressing those common
problems that developers have.
But if you are not able
to accomplish something
that you need, you're
not falling very far.
The Kubernetes itself is
still there underneath.
It gives you a comfort to be
able to adapt to the use cases
that Knative is, perhaps,
not designed for.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
If either of you
had to choose one
of your favorite features out of
Knative, what would you choose?
MARK CHMARNY: Oh,
that's a good one.
Ville?
VILLE AIKAS: I
like scale to zero.
I'm always coming up with rando
things, and I spin things up,
and then I forget about
them, and then I come in,
and I don't have to
remember to go clean up.
So if I start some jobby
job somewhere, and go home,
I don't want to halfway
through home remember
like, oh, no, I
left the stove on.
My house is going to burn down.
It's like, Knative's
going to just clean it up.
GABI FERRARA: Or
a surprise bill.
VILLE AIKAS: Yeah.
Or a surprise bill.
Yes, exactly.
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
You know, it's hard
to beat autoscaling.
We often list this on a same
level like many other features.
But I think it often goes
under-appreciated by even
the users of Knative,
because it's just there.
And when you don't look
at it, it's not there.
But when you look at it or
somebody else is looking at it
and using it, it's there.
It's pretty powerful.
I think the other
thing I would highlight
there is that when we give
people the power of Knative,
as in the easy deploying
applications, and people coming
from microservices
world were starting
to deploy 20 to 30 different
applications on top of that,
quickly realizing that
maybe not all of them
need to be exposed
to the outside world.
Maybe we should just kind of
expose one UI application,
or a service endpoint for API,
and then hide everything else.
And I think with the recent
release of 0.3 a week
or two weeks ago of Knative,
we've added to this cluster
local provisioning for services,
which, with a single label,
single attribute in a
configuration, you're saying,
this is only to be used by
other services in this cluster,
not by anybody outside.
People already are
talking about appreciating
this very much, because
it allows them a lot more
flexibility with the
type of applications
they're deploying on Knative.
MARK MANDEL: I want to dig
a little deeper on the scale
to zero part.
This is something I've
actually just remembered
I've always been thinking
about with Knative.
So in a traditional Kubernetes
world, you have pods,
and you have nodes
in your cluster.
But if you have scale
to zero on the functions
within Knative, what happens
to the nodes in that cluster?
Do you scale the nodes to zero?
How does that work?
VILLE AIKAS: Yeah.
So in that case, we do not
spin the nodes down to zero.
So the Knative doesn't
do that for you.
So we just take care
of the pods for you,
so you would have to do
something in addition
to go and actually scale
the cluster itself properly,
to go and bring the
nodes in and out.
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
Knative will deal with
optimizing the efficiency
of using your cluster.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
MARK CHMARNY: And by
creating more demand
on the physical resources, it
gives the signal to Kubernetes
to scale horizontally.
So Kubernetes will
see the pressure,
will provision a new
node, and it's probably
not something that dynamically
will happen transparently
to the users, who suddenly
need to be offloaded
to another node.
But even then, it's
getting better and better
with how fast that can be
done behind the scenes.
MARK MANDEL: So you can
use the Kubernetes node
autoscaler in conjunction?
That works?
MARK CHMARNY: Yes.
If your cluster is
configured for autoscaling,
Knative will benefit from that,
just by running on top of that.
VILLE AIKAS: Exactly.
MARK CHMARNY: So the
only other thing,
maybe perhaps adding here, in
addition to those features,
I kind of feel bad for
identifying the cluster
[INAUDIBLE] and nothing else.
Some of the things
that we've done
in the GKE version of Knative--
so if you provision Knative
using the GKE add-on, you're
obviously getting the Knative
components, but
you're also getting
a lot of additional service
integration from GCP itself.
You're getting
Stackdriver integration
for logging, some tracing
information, you get there.
You get some monitoring.
So increasingly, this feels
like a fully managed service,
even though the
open-source components,
you have to do a lot
of this yourself.
In case of GKE add-on,
it feels like something
that you can kind of say,
Google, this is your problem.
Solve that for me.
Don't page me in the middle of
the night when one of the pods
doesn't start.
I will just write
my applications.
GABI FERRARA: Ville
and Mark, what
do you expect in the future
of Knative, either open source
or on GCP?
What we should expect?
VILLE AIKAS: One of
the things that we
are working very, very hard is
making the developer experience
easy.
That part, I hope we
have convinced you of.
The other thing that we are
putting a lot of work into
is making sure that the Knative
stack itself is manageable.
So we want to make
sure that when
our operator friends,
either whether it's
at Google or some other
companies, that are running
and providing the Knative stack,
that they have the confidence
that the stack can
be managed, which
means you can go ahead and
have seamless upgrades.
When new versions roll out,
you a high degree of confidence
that everything is going to
go and just keep on running,
and everything else.
So that's where we are spending
a lot of effort right now.
That is not really
developer-facing.
But it's very, very
important to me
personally, is to ensure
that the stack itself
can be managed.
GABI FERRARA: Just a question
that pops up now in my head
when you were explaining that.
MARK CHMARNY: Uh-huh?
GABI FERRARA: I said that's
going to manage new versions,
upgrades.
Let's say, one thing like
Spectre happens again.
With Knative, would I have
to go manually patching
all my servers, or it just is
going to do everything for me,
and I don't have to
worry about that?
I just thought about
that, because we
did have that problem recently.
Not we, as we as
an IT community.
And that was a big problem.
Would Knative help in that?
VILLE AIKAS: Knative itself
wouldn't really help.
But it would be taken
advantage, basically,
of the cluster operators
that are providing
the underlying cluster.
So for example, our
tireless Google SRE folks
would just make sure
that it just goes away.
So Knative, no.
But because we are building
on top of Kubernetes,
then everything that we get
from Kubernetes and managed
Kubernetes properly is
free out of the box.
MARK MANDEL: Really
standing on the shoulders
of giants, as we say.
VILLE AIKAS: That's
exactly right.
MARK CHMARNY: And
in GKE, now we have
those flags for auto
repair and auto upgrade.
So if those two
options are checked
when you provision
to Knative, you
are benefiting from
that very thing.
You will get control,
[? plane ?] upgrade,
and you will get auto
repair of the nodes.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
VILLE AIKAS: I think coming
back to the future of Knative,
just doubling down on little
more on what Ville was saying.
With 0.3 release, I
think we really have not
talked about it
this way publicly,
but maybe we should
a little more.
It's probably the
very first release
that kind of solves for
a lot of the friction
points that we've gotten
feedback from the community.
So people, when we first
announced 0.1 release
during Next in San
Francisco, there
was a few customers
that actually
were using that at that
time, but the community
was still not providing
a lot of feedback
of actual real-world use cases.
Over the last seven
months, we actually
started getting
meaningful feedback
from actual users,
people who run
that for workloads
that, you know,
I'm not sure if they're
production, but something
that is ready to provide some
kind of meaningful feedback.
With 0.3 release, we've
actually implemented
many of the solutions for
many of the friction points
that we've heard about
from the community.
So you will see kind of
that emphasis going forward,
going all the way to the
proverbial 1.0 release, which
we will hopefully have soon.
No timelines to speak of yet.
I think that emphasis
on making sure
that people are able
to leverage that
to build real-world applications
that are not just Hello
Worlds, but something that
helps them solve real problems,
it's something that's very
close to the entire team, both
on engineering, as well
as on the product side.
We make sure that those things
are addressed or, first of all,
captured from the community
through either Slack
channels that we use, or issues
in our GitHub repositories,
or even empathy
sessions with customers,
and trying to kind of observe
how they use that system.
And then going back and
making sure that those issues
are addressed in our pretty
frequent cadence release,
which is now every six weeks.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah.
Actually, to that point,
you mentioned Slack.
If people want to get
involved with Knative,
or want to learn more,
or maybe contribute,
where should they go should?
MARK CHMARNY: They should
Ville on Twitter, first of all.
No.
[LAUGHTER]
We do have a public channel.
So the official channels
are the issues and comments.
Frankly, you don't
have to open an issue.
You can just open a comment
in a repository in GitHub.
So Github.com/knative.
You can also join
knative.slack.com
which is a whole
organization dedicated
with a number of different
channels for clients,
or monitoring, or security,
whatever is interesting to you.
And Knative Twitter is also--
KnativeProject on Twitter
is also a good place
to kind of raise concerns,
or even ask a question,
or comment.
Ville and I are also on
those social media points.
So just grab us at
conference, reach out
to anybody on the team,
and we'd definitely
love to hear from you.
VILLE AIKAS: Yeah,
and just more,
the community aspect,
the conversations
that happen in Slack.
And it's very, very
welcoming, and it's
fantastic to get new users,
new contributors, new kicking
the tires, what is this thing?
It's a great community.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, I think, actually,
we're just about out of time.
So I think we'll
wrap things up there.
I think that was great.
So Ville, Mark, thank you so
much for coming on and telling
us all about Knative.
VILLE AIKAS: Thank you
so much for having us.
That was a lot of fun.
MARK CHMARNY:
Yeah, it was great.
Thank you.
GABI FERRARA: Thank you all.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
again to Mark and Ville
for joining us on the
podcast to talk about all
the cool things Knative.
But now I have the
really hard questions
that I'm going to ask
Gabi about Cloud SQL.
Are you prepared?
GABI FERRARA: I am.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Question of the week.
How long does it take for
Cloud SQL to detect an outage
and trigger high
availability failover?
How good is our stuff?
GABI FERRARA: So short
answer, 60 seconds.
[DING]
But a lot happened to
that to be detected.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
GABI FERRARA: So every
second, the primary instance,
or your master, depending
on the terminology you use,
sends a write to our system
database, which does heartbeat.
And if it doesn't attack
a heartbeat signal
for 60 seconds, it will
trigger the failover,
and the standby instance will
be the new primary instance
that you're hiding there.
So you always have a hot
standby replica there.
And that's how long it takes
to activate the failover.
Now, the failover may take a
bit more, because it depends
on the replication, and
that's a lot of stuff
that we can cover
in another podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Sounds like we should do
a whole Cloud SQL episode.
GABI FERRARA: [LAUGHING]
Oh, I hope people
want to see that.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure they will.
Excellent.
Well, that's really
good to know.
Fantastic.
Well, Gabi, where
are you going to be?
What are you up to?
What cool things
you got going on?
GABI FERRARA: So
this February, I'll
be talking about the awesome
new features of MySQL 8.0
at PHP UK in London.
So come out and see
if you want to know
the cool tricks about MySQL 8.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
That sounds really good.
I will be at nothing immediately
in the next few weeks.
I actually need
to renew my visa.
Yes, small details.
It's a little thing.
It's fine.
[SIRENS]
GABI FERRARA: Small detail.
MARK MANDEL: But I am
looking forward to GDC.
I will be to GDC, Game
Developers Conference,
in March.
I'm really looking
forward to that.
There's going to be a really
big Google presence there.
We're going to have a booth.
We're going to
have presentations.
Keep an eye out.
We'll definitely be
talking about that more.
I will also be at Cloud Next,
as I assume you will be, Gabi.
GABI FERRARA: Yes, I will.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
probably doing various things
there as well.
So keep that on your radar.
GABI FERRARA: Databasing.
MARK MANDEL: You'll be
doing database things.
I'll probably be doing
game-y things and also
some other stuff.
And finally, this is a
little bit further out,
but in April, I will be
presenting at the East Coast
Games Conference.
I'm going to be
talking about Agones.
I'm going to actually do
some presenting about sort
of open-source strategy
as well, and why
I think the games industry
should be doing more stuff
in the open-source realm.
So that should be
kind of fun as well.
So lots of good
stuff on the horizon.
GABI FERRARA: A lot of stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Well, Gabi, thank
you so much for joining me
on the podcast.
The very first podcast
of the year, but
thank you so much
for joining me on it.
I appreciate it.
GABI FERRARA: Thank you,
Mark, for having me here.
I hope I didn't
[BLEEP] up anything.
MARK MANDEL: No, you did
a [BLEEP] wonderful job.
And thanks to everyone
for listening,
we'll see you all next week.
GABI FERRARA: See you laters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[DOG BARKING]
MARK MANDEL: That
was going to happen.
Come here.